pero también respiramos este carcinógeno.
Obviamente, no muy bueno, ¿verdad?
El otro problema es que estos adhesivos son permanentes.
¿Y qué hacen con los zapatos, el auto, o la computadora portátil
cuando se ha terminado su vida útil?
La mayoría termina en los vertederos.
Y contienen materiales valiosos que podríamos sacar y reciclar.
No es fácil hacerlo, porque están pegados de forma permanente.
Y tenemos una iniciativa para intentar resolver algunos de estos problemas:
hemos tomado otra molécula larga que podemos obtener del maíz
y pusimos en ella algo de la química de adhesión de los mejillones.
Como usamos el maíz y los mejillones
lo llamamos el polímero del surf y la hierba.
Y pega. Pega realmente bien.
Es muy fuerte.
Y tiene una base biológica, que es bueno.
Pero quizá lo más importante es que es degradable
y lo podemos degradar en condiciones suaves, con agua.
Significa que podemos reparar algo,
adherir las partes fuertemente cuando queremos,
pero también separarlas.
Es algo en lo que estamos pensando.
Y muchos querríamos estar en esta situación.
Bueno, en este caso es una situación en la que no queremos estar,
sino que queremos reemplazarla.
Suturas, grapas, tornillos...
Así hacemos las uniones cuando hay una operación o una herida.
Es horrible. Duele.
En el caso de las suturas,
observen toda la tensión mecánica y puntual para unir las cosas.
Dan lugar a infecciones,
hacen agujeros en el tejido sano. No es bueno.
O si necesitan una placa para unir los huesos,
observen cuánto hueso sano debe perforarse para sostener la placa.
Es horrible.
Para mí, parecen cosas diseñadas en una cámara de tortura medieval,
pero es nuestra cirugía moderna.
Me encantaría que podamos reemplazar sistemas como estos con adhesivos.
Estamos trabajando en esto, pero no es fácil.
Piensen qué adhesivos necesitarían en estos casos.
Primero, necesitarían adhesivos que solidifiquen en un entorno húmedo.
Y esta pequeña imagen un poco tonta
es para ilustrar que nuestro cuerpo es un 60 % agua,
que es un entorno húmedo.
También es para ilustrar por qué soy científico y no artista.
No me equivoqué para nada.
Y los otros requisitos para lograr un buen adhesivo biomédico son:
debe adherirse fuertemente, por supuesto,
y no ser tóxico.
No queremos dañar a los pacientes.
Y lograr cualquiera de esos requisitos en un material es bastante fácil.
Se hizo muchas veces. Pero conseguir los tres juntos, no.
Es muy difícil.
Y si hablamos con los cirujanos, ellos son muy quisquillosos:
"Quiero que el adhesivo solidifique dentro del mismo período de la cirugía".
O: "Quiero que el adhesivo se degrade
así los tejidos del paciente remodelan el sitio".
Así que es muy difícil. Estamos trabajando en ello.
Esta es solo una de las imágenes.
Así que conseguimos toda clase de huesos y piel,
y tejido duro y blando, y a veces los golpeamos con un martillo.
Normalmente los cortamos en forma precisa,
y después los pegamos.
Obtuvimos resultados interesantes, algunos materiales fuertes,
cosas que parecen no ser tóxicas,
que solidifican húmedas,
pero no les diré que resolvimos el problema de la adhesión húmeda,
porque no es así,
pero es una de nuestras visiones para el futuro.
Esto es algo donde me gustaría ver un avance.
Y, como pueden imaginar, hay muchas otras cosas que podríamos mejorar
si pudiéramos introducir más adhesivos.
Incluso los cosméticos.
Si piensan en la gente que usa uñas o pestañas postizas,
¿qué usan?
Actualmente están usando adhesivos muy tóxicos.
Es el momento de reemplazarlos.
Eso es algo que me gustaría hacer.
Y hay otras cosas también.
Piensen en los autos y aviones.
Cuanto más livianos son,
más eficiente es el consumo de combustible.
Y si pudiéramos liberarnos de los remaches y las soldaduras
y poner más adhesivos
quizá nos iría mejor con la futura generación de transportes.
Así que todo nos lleva de vuelta a la playa.
Miramos alrededor y nos preguntamos: "¿Cómo se pegan las criaturas marinas?
¿Qué podemos hacer con la tecnología?"
Y diría que todavía hay mucho por aprender
de la biología y de la naturaleza.
Así que me gustaría alentarlos a que en el futuro
dejen sus computadoras portátiles no reciclables y sus teléfonos móviles,
salgan a explorar el mundo natural
y empiecen a hacer sus propias preguntas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)